[音楽]
はどうも
転載ドクター始めた君たち人間というようなで
ものをくっつける時にボンドを使うわけでボンド bond やら接着剤やね色々使う
と思うんだけどもまぁ俺がねまぁ今まで前世経験した中でそんな音聴てって
最強の本鈍痛が見たことはないんでそこでを者さんが得たを手に入って来てねあらゆる
ボンドとか接着剤とかそういう類のものを片っ端から全部買ってきたわけですよここに
プラスティッキー本土 gp クリアオレさぁ木工用仮設部材ある調理蛇舌具材
ウルトラ作用とあの se 優待勝4敗とパワージェル are you doing
せるダンスところ神宮インズ境地に柔軟だ西4条疲れ
はぁプラモデル寄せみたいまあそういうボンド観測厨パワーヘラうち9みんな大好き
キャビックやなと
なんか小学校です魔本と接着剤会える神戸んだに事をつなげる分野の reit が
こちらにも生存しているわけなんですけど今日私がいるのはねこちらのボンド全部
うち混ぜておっさいきょうのねもうくっついたらそれだけなるくらいので最強の接着が
5は作ろうと思います今回は本当にしっかりやろうと思ってるね色々結構計画
てますこれは混ぜて作った奴をどう使おうかという話なんですけど
こちらのてると言わねとりあえずねー
10%増の壁がはがれたら俺多分本当に弁償モンだから袋まで予想という時は不老庵
ありがするばの天井にプレル完成した最強の接着のよ
うってそこに手袋をくっつけますってだってもしそのボンドが最強だったんだよ
その手袋なんかよりこっちを入れてもうそのまま俺は件についてキロ件数は俺の形成に
さえ耐えられたら
もう多分最強っていうのは間違いないんでほんとはねもうすぐ作りたいんですけど
瞬間接着剤とかなんか速乾性が強い捕まるのであんまりのんびりしてられませふまで
できて素敵塗って助けて袋をくっつけましょう
プーップーッん
[音楽]
もしですよもし最強のその設置ぐらいになって天井が落ちてきたら
弁償しますその時はもうちょっと僕が悪いんで弁償しますもし年でもちゃんとついても
さあやっぱこいつ分かりあーなんでねちょちゃんとで剥がすための問題だと思ってるん
で
自己責任で行っておりますあまり真似すんだよ吉田事故選議員で作ってくださ速乾性と
は瞬間接着剤で学んだからいかに早く産ませるかです
よし
一番速攻大そこそこそこそこそこそこそこだけどそこそこは速攻版そこ
単にそこまず速攻マジこれはれた曲がって暇悩みソッコ
あり即効速攻水道スピードパワースピード speed up 主
何でもおっしゃっうちやれ俺って何ですん
ています
設けカーデですのでちょっと島せる
バッハ
ぞよかっいっ
これガチで課題は一応これが最強の硬さのあるです
はもう固まってきてもう定まってきてでも年前よろしくって立ってるけど
よしあつ
よしよしやはり生活やればいい igb 何度か手袋たちがここにくっついてます全部
そっかーなんで5寸あれば完璧にくっつくと思うのでちょっと休憩ですやばいねばい
ばい
何か食べちゃううっっうわぁ
へへへー
ねまあこういうこともありましたよ
[音楽]
固まったぽいですこっちらでちょっと不安なんだよてねこの最強説裏に固まった手袋に
腕を突っ込んでこれ
懸垂をしようと思います
いくぜいや結構怖いわいや無理でしょ
いやいけるいけるいけるは絶対行きますまあ中まで浸透してある
ちょっとってっ
何でもベッドに山をする接種まず天井を押すとも知らねぇかんな
やるよはしないよねぇ
イケますよやねぇ
絶対いると思ってるんだって
世界最長の
接着剤だろう
ええええええ
car
[音楽]
しています